if a team wants to give you 430 million
dollars stay there for 12 plus years
because they knew they'd have fun then
you stay and you do that and that story
was the 430 was obviously Mike trout's
that contract Jeff Passan broke the news
and and Jeff kind of take me through
this timeline of when did this contract
get agreed upon and how long have they
been working on this deal you know it's
come together pretty quickly actually
there there was not a whole lot of
optimism even as of yesterday afternoon
among the Angels that they were going to
get this done but I think both parties
recognize that Mike Trout belongs in Los
Angeles Angels uniform when you have a
generationally great player like him you
want to keep him around and if it costs
more money than any athlete in history
has ever been paid then you pony up that
money because the idea of Mike Trout
going to Philadelphia or New York or
across you know up to up to 5 in to
Dodger Stadium that's a that's a scary
thing if you're if you're already Moreno
the owner of the Angels and he stepped
up and you know what credit do to the
Angels they have had a dreadful history
of long term contracts whether it's
Albert Pujols Josh Hamilton CJ Wilson
Gary Matthews jr. like they have not
turned out well but in this case they're
hoping that the fifth time's charm
yeah Jeff I got the list right here he
got the Bartolo Colon Vladimir Guerrero
Torii Hunter Vernon Wells at Greinke
pool hall CJ Wilson Josh Hamilton Upton
for the resigning Ian Kinsler has been a
long list but look Artie Moreno has said
like I'm going to spend money and win
championships
hopefully they haven't done that
recently but when it comes to this
contract in this deal for Mike Trout
Jeff helped me out here should angel
fans be thanking Bryce Harper for kind
of igniting that flame and forcing the
hand of the Angels to get something done
you know I don't know that there is a
direct correlation there going into the
offseason
well before Bryce Harper became a
Philadelphia Philly the Angels had
designs on extending Mike Trapp they
understood that his contract was going
to be expiring after the 2020 season and
if it got close enough you know the
question you get the free agency the
more alluring it is and that especially
goes for star players like Trout because
while the market has cratered for for
those mid to your guys Harbor still got
his 330 million Manny Machado still got
his 300 million Nolan Arenado still got
you know his 270 million I mean that
there were a lot of guys out there this
offseason who got paid and so the idea
that Mike Trout was potentially going to
be out there on the open market was
scary to the angels and they understood
that they needed to pony up that being
said the new money doesn't they gave him
is 10 years and about 365 million
dollars and if you look at that compared
to what Machado got or what Harper got
it's not that bad a deal and and I know
it's crazy to hear that like 365 million
dollars guaranteed is not a bad deal you
have to contextualize it and in the
context of what others are getting paid
right now 365 for 10 years tacking on to
the two years and 66 and a half million
that he's still owed on this deal that's
pretty good no it's really good because
when we compared to what you know was
signed a long time ago back in 2012 with
our pools you say 10 years to 40 that
was like a bargain right still when you
think about it in today's money so we my
next question for you Jeff and right
Jeff Passan the ESPN MLB insider joining
the Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison to
fill it in for rich you can also follow
Jeff on Twitter at Jeff Passan
okay so the the Mike Trout deal is done
and now we're gonna focus more on the
Angels baseball team now okay what's
next you catcher your guys sigh but they
don't have the same manager you know
Mike Scioscia who had been there since
2000 he's no longer the manager who has
coached Bryce Harper since Harper
entered the league so now they turn to
Brad Ausmus so what are we expecting now
moving forward with this angels team a
new heck new manager Brad Ausmus you
know it remains to
and I don't mean to equivocate with that
answer but it all depends on their
pitching and pitching has been
problematic for the angels they've had a
rash of Tommy John surgeries that really
have hindered their ability to develop
guys and so you're looking at Trevor
Cahill you're looking at it
Matt Harvey you're looking at guys on
one-year deals right now to sort of
bridge the gap between the return of
Shohei Otani on the mound in 2020 the
arrival of Griffin canning you know one
of their top prospects they've they've
got some arms in their organization but
the number that actually pan out as
opposed to - or just prospects you're
looking at like a 25-30 percent hit rate
on a guy so you need volume rather than
talent and and when you can combine
those two it's great the Angels don't
have a surplus of starting pitching in
the organization though which means
they're going to have to go outside and
what they can sell now is hey you get to
play with the greatest player of his
generation and maybe the greatest player
ever when it's all said and done and you
get to play with the most unique player
in a hundred years and oh by the way you
get to live in a place that's 75 and
sunny every day so like selling the
Angels is not a very difficult thing to
you but their lack of recent track
record of winning is problematic for
guys you know when you go somewhere in
free agency you want one of two things
you want to win or you want to get paid
and a lot of guys especially the best
ones can get both so the angels are
going to need to step up and continue
filling that payroll with with quality
players because what they've got right
now is not yet enough well what the
details of this contract obviously the
big question will be no trade clause no
opt-out is in any of that fine language
within this contract that that Mike
Trout possibly could be in a another
uniform outside of the Angels maybe ten
years down the road the only way Mike
Trout will be in another uniform as if
he chooses because there are no opt outs
and he has a no trade clause so he
controls his destiny and like Bryce
Harper all he wanted to do was stay in
one place
and Los Angeles Orange County is that
place for him one of the guys that you
mentioned underwent Tommy John surgery
back on October 1st was Shohei Otani now
I know pitching is out of the question
for him this season but he did take
batting practice yesterday what's the
the latest on show hey itani and his
plans for this season it's looking like
he will be back in May as the full-time
designated hitter which is crazy because
we've never seen somebody who just had
Tommy John surgery try and play a full
season before and that's because we've
never had somebody like Shelia tani I
mean he's he is an incredible athletic
specimen I think people probably don't
recognize that he runs incredibly fast
he hits the ball incredibly hard he
throws the ball incredibly hard he is
incredible in every sense of the word
but it's going to be a really
interesting story this year I think to
see just how well he can produce from
that d8 role in a near full season of it
bats when he gets back in May yeah the
reigning AL Rookie of the Year obviously
you mentioned there still needs to be
deals done for this angels team possibly
whether it's the pitching like you
mentioned they're gonna have the hitting
they believe but with some big names
still out there in free agency do you
see the Angels possibly making a run at
Craig Kimbrel or Dallas Keuchel look the
angels don't have a clear-cut closer at
this point the angels don't have a
clear-cut number one type starter at
this point I don't think Dallas Keuchel
is a one but she's certainly a guy who
would start opening day for them Craig
Kimbrel very easily would be their
closer but at the same time just because
you're spending money on my crap now
doesn't mean that you suddenly want to
go out and and rush the free agent
market and try to win this year you know
they sign them or they're going to sign
them once this deal gets finalized for
12 years and so to go out and do
something right now just for the sake of
trying to win this year I think would
probably be an ill-advised move but look
it all depends on the price I mean Craig
Kimbrel price has dropped Dallas Keuchel
prices dropped if they draw
to the range where the Angels feel
comfortable dishing out that money I
would expect them to do so it's just not
there yet Jeff Passan ESPN MLB insider
but Jeff are you surprised these guys
are still out there I mean it's been a
crazy sort of yeah MLB free agency we
waited so long for these deals Machado
Harper now trout gets him but he wasn't
a free agent but you still got to
quality all-star level players still out
there waiting for the deal like what's
going on why are these guys sign I think
both of them started off with very large
asks and they just waited they're on the
market because they felt like the market
was going to come to them it has not and
and that's where you have to recalibrate
your expectations if you are Craig
Kimbrel Craig Kimbrel or Dallas Keuchel
and I think they're there in the in the
midst of doing that at this point but
opening days 10 days away like neither
of them is going to be ready for the
beginning of the season especially
Dallas Keuchel the the likelihood is at
this point he's probably not going to be
ready till mid to late April so you know
they've lost themselves Kaiko especially
about a month of the season right now
and that's not good for anyone and it's
unfortunate but it's also reality of the
market right now the market has changed
and sometimes you got to change with it
but you don't want to change too much
because in your mind you have an idea of
what you're worth and as long as people
are offering you less than that there's
going to be an enormous reticence to
accept it because you feel like
nothing's changed at least with you
personally from the end of last season
to the beginning of this year you know
Jess you mentioned something that
opening day is right around the corner
and the Los Angeles Dodgers have had the
same opening day starter for the last
eight years it's been Clayton Kershaw
now I did some research yesterday Jeff
the last starter in 2010 other than
Kershaw Vicente Padilla those the
Dodgers starter back in 2010 yeah I
don't want to put you on the spot with
that a trivia question but you had to do
some research yesterday but that being
said Dave Robert I would I would I would
have needed
thousand guesses and I still would and
in the year before that was about it
I don't even ride iddin even remember
Vicente Padilla was with the Los Angeles
Dodgers yeah that's just god those were
some those were some dark days when
Frank McCourt was owner I was I did some
digging yesterday Jeff I was doing my
homework so then before that was Hideki
Kuroda so people do remember that name
but these are pictures that were before
Clayton Kershaw and he's been you know
obviously the stud that he is you know
one of the great pictures we think in
the game for the last with 1012 years
so what Clayton Kershaw now being well
not ready for opening day Dave Roberts
came out say that yesterday what do we
think of Clayton Kershaw now in this
season if he's not the day one starter
how do they really feel about a guy that
they even extended a contract to him
well I think they're worried about his
health and and that's the big question
at this point what Clayton Kershaw are
we going to see is this rest for his arm
going to reinvigorate and or is it going
to be the guy who during the playoffs
last year was sitting 90 with a with a
slider at 88 and when you have no
separation between those two pitches or
a very minimal separation hitters are
going to key on it
I personally expect Clayton Kershaw to
be back and to be good again and and
that's not based on any inside
information that I have
that's just my knowledge of who he is as
a person how much he cares and and his
ability to will himself to do really
incredible things I think he's an
extremely smart pitcher a crafty guy
despite the fact that he's for so long
has made his bones and excuse me as a
power pitcher but but there may be an
adjustment period as he gets into his
thirties here where he needs to reinvent
himself I don't know if we're at that
point yet but plenty of other great
pitchers have done so and and if that is
Clayton Kershaw's lot in baseball at
this point that's something that I
expect him to do willingly and do well
yeah Hiroki Kuroda I mentioned and
Vicente Padilla the two previous
pitchers for the Dodgers on opening day
other than Clayton Kershaw in the last
111 years
so that was my research from yesterday
Jeff I'm glad I can stump you for a
little bit on that one thank you I
appreciate you making me look stupid on
the air that is your job no no no you
did great today you you it's this
morning trust me I'm hitting that I I'm
listen I am anytime a football player
can come and make me feel stupid about
baseball I actually applaud it like
that's like good on you man mommy who
and and that's a good that is a that is
a great trivia question it is that is a
spectacular trivia quiz hey you can take
it use it with all day today don't worry
about it Jeff
I appreciate the time by the way I
appreciate that I am absolutely going to
steal it from you and I I know that
sounds like I was trying to make you
feel bad I promise that was not the
intention at all I I legitimately am in
awe of you for for figuring that out and
and thank you for not asking me because
that would have really made me listen
all good man I appreciate the time Jeff
I'll be looking for that tweet today by
the way so I'll be looking out for
appreciated that was Jeff passing the
ESPN MLB insider at Jeff Passan on
Twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience